[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir en
direct joëlle mélin députée européenne
au rassemblement national bonsoir madame
ménard merci beaucoup d'être avec soin
en direct dans ce face à face sur ce
plateau stéphane pellet vice-président
du mouvement la france vraiment bonsoir
à vous également
première question ces fameux appelé
est-ce que emmanuel macron eu raison de
mettre la pression avec le pass annie
terre finalement est-ce que c'est un
outil que vous jugez efficace dans la
lutte contre le coc vide même si
évidemment vous n'êtes pas un
scientifique a échappé à personne si je
suis un scientifique docteur mais pas en
médecine mais c'est pour la présenter
que je dis ça par ailleurs ce que je
crois c'est que il ne faut pas tirer de
conséquences et de conclusions
définitives sur toutes ces questions il
faut être très tranquille il faut
regarder l'état du pays et surtout le
comparer sur le plan international ce
soir la nouvelle zélande s'apprête à
rouvrir progressivement ses frontières
parce que elle a bien géré sa crise
sanitaire et au même moment le japon par
exemple ou les jeux paralympiques et
olympiques se sont déroulés
contrairement à ce qu'on pense le japon
et ce soir un pays complètement
claquemuré parce qu'il n'a eu aucune
stratégie efficace c'est exactement le
cas de l'australie qui elle par contre a
tenté une autre stratégie et kate objet
aussi de se re confiné donc ça signifie
qu'en fait chaque état je crois a tenté
une parade et moi je suis pas là ce soir
même si c'est un face à face mais en
tout cas je ne suis pas là pour défendre
spécifiquement le président de la
république il y aura un moment c'est
l'élection présidentielle où il sera
question de son bilan ce que je peux
dire c'est que
grosso modo la plupart des français lui
font confiance dans cette stratégie
contrairement à ce qu'on pense et on va
en parler bien sûr il ya des gens dans
la rue bien sûr il ya une contestation
mais quand on voit que
64% des français seront bientôt vacciner
complètement totalement même si ensuite
un rappel n'est pas une troisième dose
d'ailleurs et c'est pas à la médecin qui
est là ce soir que je vais la prendre
des vaccins on en fait toute notre vie
il ya des rappels il ya y compris les
rappels à 45 ans pour certains vaccins
quand on sait que les 18 29 ans ont pris
conscience complètement de l'intérêt de
ce pass est la vaccination et que ce
soir ils sont
74% à être vacciné je me dis que oui le
président de la république a bien fait
d'être dans une stratégie extrêmement
énergique et donc ce soir je pense que
les gens vaccinés et les gens conscients
réalistes pragmatiques sont très très
majoritaires dans ce pays un jouet mais
la même analyse que stéphane penet on
rappelle que vous êtes médecins en
formation même si vous n'exercez plus
déjà aussi même question pour vous
est-ce que cet outil a été
efficace contre la pandémie est ce que
il y avait le choix finalement au pour
ou contre
le choix on nous l'a retirée on nous l'a
retiré parce que malgré des sommes très
importantes de recherches qui ont été
mises sur la table dès le mois de
janvier 2020 on ne nous a proposé aucune
alternative et les quelques essais qui
ont été faits au moins un titre
compassionnel c'est à dire quand on n'a
rien d'autre ont été rejetées d'un
revers de main voire même condamné je
pense à l'ivermectine je pense à la
chloroquine on ne s'est pas donné les
moyens de prouver que ça ne marchait pas
vous vous rendez compte à quel point on
en met deux contre-preuve et en matière
de responsabilité là contre-preuve
n'existe pas en conséquence on n'a pas
eu d'autre choix que cette vaccination
est la marche est tant bien que mal
pourquoi parce que nous vaccinons
actuellement à propos d'une souche de
l'initiale j'entends la première
épidémie la première vague qui a déjà
disparu depuis plus d'un an donc elle
marche de moins en moins bien sûr des
mutants elle en est vite entre nous soit
dit relancer vite quand même les formes
graves et elle a permis de passer un
certain cap mais tout ceci est
terriblement un parfait tout autant que
le pass sanitaire qui scientifiquement
ne tient pas vraiment la route il ya
trop de trous dans la raquette somme
tout ça et vite
80% des contaminations vous allez me
dire c'est beaucoup mieux que rien de la
même façon qu'on a vu renaître des
règles sanitaires extraordinaire qu'on
avait complètement perdu et c'est ainsi
que l'on a eue de grippe ou presque plus
de gastro ou presque je suis allé
regarder dans la littérature il y a même
une diminution des morts subites du
nourrisson pratiquement plus de
varicelle à part quelques épidémie qui
sont surgit par de si de là presque plus
de ces maladies pour lesquelles je
rappelle quand même que l'on a proposé
et que l'on a imposé aux vaccins
obligatoires en début 2018 ça n'a pas
fait tiquer les parents cette
association de 11 l'acsa n'a pas été
évalué et donc là il ya un vrai oui
voilà bien vrai
votre réalité marseillaise que je salue
étant moi même originaire de cette très
belle ville
si je comprends bien le choix
essentiellement aurait dû être peut-être
celui la vaccination obligatoire et
peut-être d'ailleurs irons nous conte
sur ces maladies là
tous les cas c'est ce qu'il ya derrière
notre débat justement inzaghi goa on l'a
vu dans ce témoignage de lucas léger
nous dit la vaccination c'est l'enjeu de
de la rentrée clairement vous êtes
d'accord avec ceux des no 6 a va être
cet enjeu clairement de la vaccination
obligatoire là pour le moment parle du
pass sanitaire mais on a toujours dit
que c'est une forme de deux vaccinations
obligatoires qui ne disait pas son nom
c'est d'ailleurs le reproche qui lui est
fait non je pense pas que ce soit ce
débat là qui va structurer les
prochaines élections et la prochaine
élection présidentielle par contre oui
très probablement il y aura un débat
entre
des gens plutôt appuyé sur la raison et
puis ceux qui sont plutôt appuyé sur
l'expression disons de sentiment et je
mets pas là une ligne de partage
péjorative un entendait bien mais je ne
considère pas que ceux qui sont dans le
rationnel en forcément raison et ce
qu'ils ont le sentiment rector vous le
savez il ya nos grandes ceis sociologue
qui vient de sortir un livre assez
intéressant qui s'appelle donc qui parle
des sentiments de la vie et qui montre
comment progressivement les luttes celle
que vous montrez dans la rue par exemple
sont passés de luttes sociales
salariales pour la défense entre classes
à des luttes de plus en plus simplement
pour la reconnaissance le respect et ça
oui je pense que ça sera une ligne de
fracture très très forte c'est pour ça
que je vous le dis moi je ne défends pas
à plus le président de la république que
les autres le débat va se structurer
mais il est clair qu'il y aura un débat
entre une forme d'action publique
respectueuse et une formes d'action
publique peut être un petit peu trop
cassante un petit peu 3 arrogant pas
assez respectueuse et il est clair
qu'avec le mouvement que je représente
ici ce soir le mystère des citoyens la
france vraiment nous défendons une
approche respectueuse nous pensons que
plutôt que nous nous appuyer sur des
peurs et de faire descendre les gens
dans la rue il faut s'appuyer sur la
concertation les citoyens pour faire
émerger des solutions et peut-être qu'on
va y venir mais nous avons par exemple
une grande concertation en cours sur le
système de santé avant de vous revenez
la parole joël ménard je voudrais vous
faire justement écouter emmanuel macron
un café de la vaccination impôts dit un
thème politique de rentrée souvenez vous
de son allocution le 12 juillet dernier
en fonction de l'évolution de la
situation nous devrons sans doute nous
poser la question de la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous les français
faites vous vacciner c'est la seule
façon de vous protéger et de protéger
les autres c'est une question de
responsabilité individuelle
de sens de l'esprit collectif
c'était aussi ce dont dépend notre
liberté à toutes et tous joëlle mélin
clairement là on est au coeur du débat
et on est dans ce débat qui fait bondir
tous ces nantis pas sanitaire cette
forme de privation de liberté je
m'adresse à la médecin que vous êtes
mais également à celle qui appartient au
rassemblement national donc faut-il
rendre la vaccination obligatoire
écoutez c'est un faux débat c'est un
faux débat parce que l'ont été sur des
principes quasi philosophique ou de
liberté ce que j'entends parfaitement et
qui se conçoit sauf que on a
complètement oublié que le vrai problème
c'est un virus complètement inhabituelle
dont on ne connaît pas l'origine qui a
des particularités qu'on a jamais vu
même la grippe espagnole n'a fait que 2
hiver et en été on n'a jamais vu de
virus qui nous fasse maintenant 8 c'est
pratiquement deux hivers deux étaient
pratiquement 4 mais il faut savoir quand
même que cette épidémie était
probablement en route en juillet 2019 en
chine
donc nous sommes avec un virus tout à
fait extraordinaire nous ne pouvons pas
nous positionner actuellement pour la
simple et bonne raison c'est qu'avec un
peu de chance on va échapper à la suite
la suite et c'est ce qui se profile je
vous rappelle quand même qu'il ya un
virus colombien est un virus sud
africains qui sont très compliqué ici là
aussi de mutation complexe il faudra
bien voir comment on aborde tous à
l'urgence des urgences et pas se poser
le problème de savoir si oui ou non la
vaccination doit être obligatoire c'est
qui va se charger de préparer par avance
des vaccins en catastrophe sur ces deux
virus si tenté qu'il fasse le tour de
monde en s2 l'est en ouest comme on l'a
eue maintenant depuis deux ans donc
après il ya deux attitudes soit celle
qu'on a toujours eu à l'égard de
certains vaccins qui était de les
recommander de les conseiller fortement
et la solution de l'obligatoire n'est
que dans certains cas très précis et en
particulier les virus qui ne mute pas je
rappelle quand même que différer je
pense surtout à la po lyon qui est une
maladie très grave dont le virus n'est
pas mon temps mais qu'il faut absolument
garder parce que les dégâts sont
considérables et qu'actuellement ce
n'est pas un virus anodin loin de là il
faudrait pas qu'ils apparaissent donc on
est obligé de garder cette vaccination
obligatoire mais le problème de dire à
la rentrée on vaccine obligatoirement
pas c'est un faux débat oh c'est pas ce
qui va se passer à la rentrée on ne sait
pas ce qui se passera au mois de janvier
surtout si l'on voit apparaître des
épidémies comme on l'a vu très
régulièrement je vous rappelle l'automne
précédent le varia anglais on le laisse
entrer parce que les frontières ça
n'existe plus puis le gardien delta on
le laisse entrer parce que les
frontières n'existent plus honnêtement
tout ça aurait dû être arrêté beaucoup
plus tôt il y à des fautes de gestion
extrêmement lourde je vous parlais tout
à l'heure une autre faute de gestion
plus pour mon avis en chine uniquement
beaucoup plus lourd dans qu'est un point
de vue légèrement différent avec tout le
respect que je vous dois en tous les cas
pour votre parcours sur le plan
universitaire
vous parlez d'un sujet mais j'allais
dire c'est un débat que vous pourriez
avoir si tel était le cas éventuellement
avec le ministre de la santé donc
stratégique entre stratégie on peut
quand même dire que globalement la
stratégie en france a été relativement
réussies on n'y peut rien c'est comme ça
qu'on soit pour ou contre le président
de la république je pense que on peut
être aller très longtemps un certain
nombre de considérations
ce dossier m'a alors justement ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que pourquoi d'ailleurs
le président parce que c'est une
émission où on analyse aussi un peu les
choses sur leur ressenti politique
pourquoi le président insiste tant sur
la vaccination c'est parce que je pense
qu'il aliments il a l'idée de tenir sa
victoire au bout d'un certain niveau de
vaccination qui est en effet le
probablement effacera une gestion qui a
été beaucoup plus difficile concernant
les masques et d'autres d'autres
péripéties mais qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir de cette crise nous pas une
attaque comme le fait madame qui quoi
qu'on en dise fait partie de cette
formation politique est un peu celle qui
joue les apprentis sorciers pour la
plupart des mouvements sociaux qui se
retrouve avec les gilet jaune qui se
retrouve avec ces gens dont on voit des
des pancartes totalement lamentable qui
se met en place ce mouvement sans forme
finalement ce mouvement un petit peu
comme ça avec des tas de revendications
qui ne ce qui ne se complètent pas à la
fin qu'est ce que ça donne dans les
urnes d'abord souvent rien du tout la
vue aux régionales on a vu le plafond de
verre auquel s'est confronté le
rassemblement national c'est à dire que
la plupart de ces quarts ni là n'ont pas
réussi à s'imposer dans les régions
parce que les gens ont été extrêmement
comment dire claire réalistes ils se
sont dit non on préfère avant des gens
relativement sérieux plutôt que des gens
qui peu agitée sur ces questions là et
puis surtout ce qui va être intéressant
par contre c'est de savoir comment dans
la prochaine campagne va prendre en
compte l'avis des citoyens et c'est là
que je dis que nous avons une grande
différence sur ce plateau c'est que je
crois qu'il ya en effet un besoin de
concertation il ya énormément citoyens
qui ne sont pas satisfaits même si je
corrige une information sur votre
plateau vous vous disiez 30% seulement
des gens s'apprêtait à voter c'est faux
le dernier sondage pour la
présidentielle on a 70 % d'intentions
d'aller vaud oui c'est ça mais oui mais
bon peu importe c'est un invité mais
normalement il vaut mieux corriger
puisqu'il est éditorialiste de votre
chaîne sait que 70 des français se
déclarent prêts à aller voter ils sont
encore motivés c'est pour ça que ce soir
mois plus tôt ou de manière différente
de madame je lance un appel notamment à
tous les citoyens mobilisés dans les
collectifs dans les associations
citoyennes leurs nombreuses lille a
plutôt soutenir éventuellement une
candidature qui seraient issus de ce
mouvement citoyen car qu'est-ce qui a
marqué tous ces mouvements c'est qu'ils
n'ont débouché sur rien du tout enfin
c'est quand même la parole à la jeune
lena qui va peut-être vous répondre
oui oh je vais vous répondre à de la
même façon que je le fais depuis bientôt
30 ans à ce genre de considérations
voilà dont acte je voudrais quand même
faire remarquer une chose fondamentale
vous qui dites que la gestion de la
crise n'a pas été si mauvaise que ça que
tout compte fait passer il n'y a plus
rien à voir on en est bientôt à la fin
ou autrement je tombais me dire les
choses
simplement si je suis bien informé
votre ministre lui ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque à l'autre de
l'époque au mois de mars 2000 va quand
le ms a proclamé la pandémie a refusé
aurait refusé d'activer la cellule de
crise ordinaire du ministère de
l'intérieur qui permet à tous les
services de sécurité civile de se mettre
en route et d'être ensuite alimentés par
les mères via les préfets de département
je ne remets pas quels sont votre le
sérieux de votre argument l'autre là
vous avez raison
pardonnez moi on l'achète à coeur de
jouer
voilà à partir de là la gestion de la
crise a été prise à rebours est confiée
aux ars dont on a tous vu qu'elles ont
évidemment accompagné des discours qui
était en retard en permanence
d'information en particulier ceux de
santé publique france on aurait environ
fera le point dès l'instant qu'on
sentira % un peu de cette crise on fera
le point sinon il faut garder toute son
énergie pour
bat contre l'épidémie au delà de ça je
suis tout à fait étonné autant de
français vivent avec des peurs
irrationnelles
il est urgent que les politiques les
rassure qu'on cesse d'avoir des peurs
sorti de nulle part sans aucun fondement
scientifique moi j'entendais même pas
des raisonnements les gens me disent une
partir et moi je
vous êtes bien isolé dans votre
formation politique à vouloir faire en
sorte que les français n'aient plus peur
alors que c'est le carburant principal
de votre candidate oui oui pourrait
coûter cher monsieur je vous laisse ce
genre de phrase parce que voilà encore
une fois de son temps là je la fum large
et laisse penser selon les élections il
ya des moments dans tout parti politique
quel est le parti politique qui existe
comme cela depuis 40 ans et plus même
s'il a un petit peu changé de tant de
noms entre temps il n'y en a pas il n'ya
que le nôtre est le nôtre tient le coup
largement il y à eau et des bas dans une
période si longue il ya forcément des
hauts et des bas et particulièrement
nous avons nous une idée extrêmement
clair d'une doctrine su fonder en fonder
sur ce que nous croyons de ce que nous
devons apporter aux citoyens dans leur
liberté leur place et le respect qu'on
leur doit mais au delà de ça nous avons
aussi une idée de la place de l'état de
l'état qui doit offrir un cadre
sécuritaire le cadre de toutes les
sécurités la sécurité physique la
sécurité de tous les jours et dans la
rue mais aussi la sécurité sanitaire et
cette sécurité sanitaire elle a été
bafouée très gravement très gravement
par le gouvernement macro mettant à mal
toute l'économie voilà j'étais très
sincèrement l'économie s'il ya bien un
domaine sur lequel ce pays a réussi
c'est bien celui là on a passé près d'un
hôtel à approcher
si également à vous joëlle mélin d'avoir
été avec nous en direct